depuis de nombreuses années marie
trintignant suivez les traces de son
père le comédien jean-louis trintignant
et de sa mère nadine réalisatrice marie
trintignant était en lituanie pour
tourner un téléfilm où elle incarnait la
romancière colette alexandra garde
revient sur sa carrière
marie trintignant avait cette voix grave
ce regard intérieur qui lui donnait
douceur et fermeté fille de la
réalisatrice nadine et du comédien jean
louis trintignant mari était une enfant
de cinéma van houtte est très jeune de
plateau en plateau à 4 ans elle apparaît
pour la première fois à l'écran dans un
téléfilm réalisé par sa mère à 16 ans
elle vint sa timidité il donne la
réplique à patrick dewaere série noire
et le fils qui l'a lancé mais ce mois
faire et cassent pas les pieds
l'adolescente voulais être vétérinaire
finalement elle sera comédienne mais une
comédienne incarnant le plus souvent des
personnages décalés marginaux suicidaire
dans des nouvelles du bon dieu de didier
le pêcheur cleptomane et fétichiste dans
le cri de la chouette jean-mi comme
annie arnaqueuse dans comme elle respire
aux côtés de guillaume depardieu
j'aime bien tourner avec marie parce que
d'abord n'allait pas chiante comme
toutes les autres comédiennes et et puis
en plus à l'est elle est jolie joue bien
plus récent bond elle ramène très envie
de chercher dont je suis presque le
temps pour se protéger de ces rôles
difficiles mari à la poésie l'écriture
et la rêverie qu'elles prolongent
parfois jusqu'au bout de la nuit
marielle note des choux des notes des
phrases elle crée l événement la poésie
et les
l'écriture moi ce que je veux c'est son
bonheur c'est avec son père en 1999
qu'elle rend hommage à guillaume
apollinaire ensemble ils récitent les
célèbres poèmes à lou le récit d'un
amour fou entre un père et sa fille
je voudrais que tu sois là pour noé mais
dans les ténèbres
je voudrais que tu sois ma fille pour
être par toi seul
elle me surprendre beaucoup par son
sérieux
eksi et puis elle me surprend aussi
quand même elle est très étonnante comme
kilian est vraiment très étonnante
teller 60 films et ses quatre enfants
marie a vécu mille vies
la dernière trop éphémère fut celle de
colette la romancière qu'elle incarnait
à l'écran au moment du drame